Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible].
What do you see here is that.
Band of vector images.
The vector images are not like most images that you see on the internet.
Those are Esther images, and those are like photos and are made of pixels.
While vector images are not made of pixels, they are made of shapes.
These vector images have lots of advantages.
They have really small fire sizes can be zoomed into as much as we
desire and things don't get pixelated.
And Hans vector images are really well suited for logos, user interface,
icons, and more. Now, if we wish to,
we can convert vector images into raster images.
So the shapes will become pixels. This is easy,
but here's the problem. If we do it once,
there is no going back or at least not easily.
This method promises to make this conversion a two-way street.
So we can take a raster image, a photo, if you will,
and work with it as if it were a vector image. Now,
what does that mean? Oh boy, a lot of goodies, for instance,
we can perform sculpting or in other words,
manipulating shapes without touching any pixels,
we can work with the shapes here is that much easier,
or my favorite perform painterly rendering.
Now what you see here is not the new algorithm performing this.
And this is a genetic algorithm. I wrote a few years ago.
That takes a target image,
which is the MonaLisa here takes a bunch of randomly colored triangles
and starts reorganizing them to get as close to the target image as
possible.
And the source code and a video explaining how it works is available in the
video description.
And now let's see how this new method performs on a similar task.
It can start with a large number of different shapes and just look at how
beautifully these shapes evolve and start converging to the target image,
loving it, but that's not all.
It also has a nice solution to an old, bad,
challenging problem in computer graphics that is referred to as seam carving.
If you ask me, I like to call it image squishing, why?
Well, look here,
this gives us an easy way of intelligently squishing an image into different
aspect ratios. So good.
So can we measure how well it does what it does?
How does it compare to add obese state of the art method when vectorizing
affordable? Well, it can not only do more,
but it also does it better.
The new method is significantly closer to the target image here.
No question about it. And now comes the best part.
It not only provides higher quality results than the previous methods,
but it only takes approximately a second to perform all this.
Wow. So there you go. Finally, with this technique,
we can edit pixels as if they weren't pixels at all.
It feels like we are living in a science fiction world. What a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by Lambda GPU cloud.
If you're looking for inexpensive cloud GPU's for AI,
check out Lambda GPU cloud,
they recently launched Quadro RTX 6,000 RTX,
8,000 and V 100 instances and hold onto your papers
because Lambda GPU cloud can cost less than half of AWS
and Azure.
Plus they are the only cloud service with 48 gigabyte RDX, eight thousands.
Join researchers at organizations like Apple, MIT,
and Caltech in using Lambda cloud instances, workstations or servers,
make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today.
Our thanks to Lambda for the longstanding support and for helping us make better
videos for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.